on va rester dans les états unis
puisqu'il est avec nous il vient ce soir
pour vous portal pour arnaud ducret pour
vous chers téléspectateurs
il revient d'une tournée triomphale sur
cergy pontoise sur gueugnon sur guingamp
c'est jamie foxx traque
pense qu'un deal oui on va vous faire
jouer également chez donner un truc là
si djibril salut aux blacks faire c'est
exceptionnel sur le plateau c'est
quelqu'un du combal qui arrive aussi je
sais très bien que j'adore quel bel
homme très très bel homme
je vous ai présenté pineau lara sera mon
pianiste issus de mon nouveau spectacle
vive la téloche oui c'est bien le neuf
la bannière de maurice béjart qui nous
regardent de là haut
oui plusieurs personnalités du paf
oui oui à il est passé d oui oui oui oui
oui avec de nouvelles positions de
démarrage qui vont vous faire plaisir
dont une délégation des gens de l'équipe
donc on essaie de trouver des
personnages de télé sur des bases aussi
d'accéder à la salle et ont des marges
tout de suite par une position de jean
michel maire au cap d'agde à partir ta
musique sur un bordeaux voici la
première questions du quiz de jimmy
foxtrot
a paris il anime des chiffres et des
lettres à bonbons chihuahua mais c'est
harry potter mais mentalement il a la
carte vermeil entre charme
une famille imprononçable tellement
bizarre qu'on dirait qu'il a été trouvé
avec un bagel épilation du stif yade et
animaux si la météo depuis le xviiie
siècle saut de l'ange
alors que tata les ados de se retrouver
le petit adam les cap d'agde c'est qui
c'est quoi il s'appelle 2013 nous fait
j'ai trouvé ici me connais pas mais je
m'y attendais un mot sur quatre donc
c'était très prometteur laurent romejko
bonnes réponses
allez deuxième personnage et bravo je
trouve que vous dansiez encore mieux
qu'avant
merci copa aux blacks impressionnants
mais l'animateur à la peau d'ébène me
fais des compliments
ensuite nous allons donc passer de même
chorégraphie démarrage en position du
caca dans les fougères
mais nick sur une rumba
voici la deuxième question du quiz de
jean foxtrot
bonsoir il commente les généraux sur
france télé rumbach rumba il parle un
anglais impeccable sa chasse et smack
bonsoir c'est le dernier dans le monde à
porter des vestes en tweed avec des
motifs pied de poule et des pantalons de
schepper tâche up sell sa tentative
cette charmante hâtives et sur une aile
il a des poils de schneck
un journaliste qui commente la vie au
temps mais j'étais tellement sur les
mouvements mais que c'est qu'ils ne sont
nelson monfort répondu me souviens pas
c'est le troisième chez vous je suis sûr
vous avez trouvé les deux premiers c'est
le texan là le troisième à les positions
si bleu manpower pour démarrer sur un
merengue salsa danse du cul cul voici la
troisième question du quiz jimmy foxtrot
c'est une star venue du québec merengue
mais rêver il fait partie du jury de the
voice chat ta gueule il a une touche de
deux mètres cubes
en grande que ses crottes de nez
pour la taille d'une boule de bowling
alors ticket cul du cul
et quand ils sont
noah chi de bougie rend techamerica
j
merci alors talent est ce que vous
l'avez sous les eaux et garou garou ses
réponses de telles demandes d'après pas
le génie jimmy fax transmis la danse à
vous
21 manches on ne m'a pas une fois
cartonne sur davies est entre 7h et 9h
avec vincent desagnat et bien sûr
stéphanie doit arriver demain bien sûr à
cette heure
oh